desde el comienzo en la invasión rusa
siempre se habló de que desearon los
grandes objetivos del gobierno de moscú
se han dado varias explosiones a lo
largo de esta semana sin embargo la que
más ha impactado en la ciudad sucedió en
este edificio a mis espaldas que fue ha
tocado hace exactamente hace una semana
por un misil según las fuerzas rusas era
un misil que estaba dirigido a un
depósito donde se guardaban armas el
aeropuerto no está muy lejos de aquí sin
embargo impactó en los primeros pisos de
este edificio donde viven generalmente
parejas jóvenes entre ellos murió una
madre valeria con su hija de tres meses
y su madre pero no solamente ella en un
piso más arriba vivía otra mujer que
acababa de contarle a su gran amiga que
estaba embarazada
eso me des en friday ella me dijo el
viernes me dijo que posiblemente yo
podría darle algunas cosas algunos
juguetes para niños porque tengo dos
niños también alguna ropa era una
conversación de mujeres y estaba muy
feliz y al día siguiente murió murió con
su marido los dos es que hasta que llegó
dos días después de que un alto general
ruso volviera a recordar que uno de los
grandes objetivos de moscú es tomar toda
la costa incluido o de esa que es el
gran puerto sobre el mar y negro y
también solamente ayer hubo una
explosión en el aeropuerto otro misil
atacó la pista de la aviación comercial
de la ciudad que no está operativa hace
dos meses la gente tiene susto pero
también nos dicen que han ido
habituándose al ritmo de la guerra
cuando oyen las sirenas ahora lo hacen
con mayor seguridad van y buscan refugio
ya sea los sub terrenos de sus casas o
en lugares seguros sin embargo muchos de
ellos han decidido quedarse dicen que
tienen que aprender
con esta situación y están a la
expectativa de saber qué puede pasar en
las próximas semanas y también meses